we have some breaking news from the  Thames Valley police they're saying that  human remains found in a loft space at a  property in first and in Milton Keynes  where they have been confirmed as the  body of Leah Croucher in a statement the  Thames Valley police have said officers  investigating the murder of Leah  Croucher in Milton Keynes can today  confirm that she has been formally  identified a home office post-mortem  which was conducted last week has been  inconclusive as to the cause of Leah's  death and investigations are continuing  a murder investigation was launched last  week following the discovery of Lear in  The Loft space of two Larkspur Drive in  Thurston in Milton Keynes